(cheering)
- You look cute.
- Thank you.
- Green is my favorite color.
- No, it's mine, too.
'Cause money, girl, money.
- A lot of other things
that are green are nice.
- Who don't like green?
- Yeah. Everything awesome is green.
- There's a lot of green in the audience.
♪ Money, money, money ♪
(Kelly laughs)
- It's nice to see you in person.
Last time it was in the Skype era
like when we were all in Zoom.
- Oh yeah.
When we did the Zoom thing.
- [Kelly] Yes, you're physically here now.
- I miss those days.
- You do? Because it is kind of nice.
You don't have to wear pants.
- I was butt naked half the time.
I just had a shirt on and I'd
do my Zoom interview, so--
- I gotta be honest with you, I loved it.
I had like no hair and makeup.
I was just sitting there like with an iPad
or I mean a computer
and I was just doing it.
It was kinda nice.
- Dude, I had a vat of
wine like Game of Thrones.
I was like.
(Kelly laughing)
- God. (laughs)
- I miss those days.
Now we gotta get up and be
responsible, like adults.
- But you know what? But now we look,
we can see you though
and you look really nice.
- Thank you.
- So well done.
- Yeah.
- Thank you.
- So the first time--
- I like your cheetah print.
- Thank you.
- I like your--
- I was feeling like an animal.
I didn't plan this at all.
My stylist did.
So, but the first time
- I was up all night.
I don't know what you're
talking about, Boo.
(Kelly laughing)
- It's like green, the black.
No, the first time Marlon was here.
His kids were unfollowing him
on social media because
you embarrassed them.
And now we have found out
that your son is now
asking you to embarrass him
by rating his looks on social.
So we just wanna, we just
wanna show this to everybody.
- All right. So here's the next fit.
- Yes. All right.
I don't like the Scooby Doo shirt.
But I like the Shaggy pants.
Oh, I don't know what sneakers those are.
Those look...
- They're the New Balances.
- They're too white guys,
Stranger Things for me.
- All right. Rate the fit.
- Yeah. Four.
- But look at the bag.
Oh two, sorry.
- Oh my God!
So (chuckles),
my first thing about it,
if you watch it again,
it looks like your son
is holding your head.
Like you have to be a part of it.
It looks like his hand
is behind your head,
like forcing you to be a part of it.
- That, that's just how
he's always been with me.
It's like his -- it's
like a form of affection.
- [Kelly] Oh!
- He just kind of grabs my head.
He's like, "Dad! Dad!"
And he navigates my
neck where he wants it.
And he used to do that when he's a kid.
When he was like three,
he would, "Dad! Dad!"
and move my head everywhere.
And I, and now he's 20
and he's still like, "Dad, dad, dad."
- He just wants you to focus.
- Yeah. That's what it is.
Cause he knows I got ADD.
Like, I'm talking to you
but I wanna talk to every
last single one of them.
And every last single one of them.
- Oh great.
- And then talk to people back there.
I just wanna, I like, you know
I see everything like a, like a fly.
And so he just tries to get me to focus.
And it's funny 'cause he
unfollowed me on social media.
Now you want to be a
part -- me to be a part
of your social media.
Oh, how the tides have turned, little boy.
(Kelly laughs)
- I am ADHD.
So this interview should go well.
- Oh, perfect.
- We're both gonna be like "Squirrel".
(Marlon laughs)
So wait, we found another
fashionable guy for you to rate.
- Okay.
- So here
we just wanted you to take a,
what do you think about
this look right here?
This is pretty good.
Pretty good.
It's from like '98 maybe
- I was ahead of my time.
If you look at it, you know.
Now everybody wanna wear
the baggy stuff again.
Eh? See? Look at that.
- I love that the
baggies come back around.
I do love that.
- I'll get outta, that's about
a, you know, I give it about
I ain't have no chest, so I
if I had a chest, it'd be a 10.
So that's about an eight.
I'll give it an eight.
- Oh, you do eight.
That's nice. That's nice.
- Yeah, I grew a chest last year.
- You grew a chest.
- Yeah, I'm late with my puberty thing.
- Okay, so we have one more.
So here we go.
We're gonna look at this one.
What, what do you rate this one?
(crowd cheers)
My, my favorite part, in my mind
there's no scar or anything wrong.
You just are wearing the bandaid.
- I was like 14 in that picture so
I'm pretty sure there was a
pimple behind that bandaid.
- I know. I was like --
- But I don't, I don't, I'll be honest
I don't really like the, the
jack-- the, the, the vest.
It looked heavy and hot.
Looked like it make my underarm stink.
So I'm
- I know, but at the
time this was rocking.
- I like the Girbaud pants.
- Yeah. This was
- But once again, I didn't
have a chest. So I'm
- I like your eyes too.
Look at your eyes.
You're serious about it.
- Oh, the eyes, with the eyebrow?
- Yeah. You were serious about it.
- Girl, the eye eyebrow says
- Smirk.
You ain't ready for this.
That's what it says.
- So I give the eyebrow --
I give an outfit of four.
I give the eyebrow a 13.
- It's just
So wait, since you're
the baby of the family
did your brothers or sisters,
did they give you a hard time growing--
I'm the baby in my family.
- I'm the baby.
Like your baby and your
family could get like love.
- No, we...
- I'm the baby of 10 comedians.
So you have to understand
I'm the butt of every joke.
- Yeah.
- So they--
- That was my life.
- Every sister almost
killed me in some way.
- Okay, no.
Wait, what? No.
- My sister Devonne, she,
I accidentally ate a vitamin E pill
and she said, "Marlon you're gonna die."
I said, "What?!"
She goes, "So the only way you can fix it
"you gotta drink nine
glasses of whole cold water,
"eight glasses of warm water
and six glasses of hot water."
Girl, I almost drowned. (laughs)
I was sitting in the bed with
water spilling out my mouth.
My belly was filled up to here.
She goes, "Don't tell mama."
I was like (chuckles).
- Oh my Gosh!
- And then she bribed me with a Tic-Tac
and put that in my mouth with the water
drooling out my mouth.
I didn't tell mama, but I did almost die.
That was, that was interesting.
- Okay. That was a little more intense.
Mine, one of my siblings gave me
chocolate covered dog food
and said it was candy.
(audience laughs)
- That's not bad.
- Honestly, it tasted like chocolate, so
- Every last sibling has probably farted
on me from the ages of one
- Did they do the spit thing
where they suck it back up?
They pin you down, they spit
and then they suck it back up?
- No, that's gross.
- Exactly!
I'm telling you.
Do you know that I
have a complete phobia
of saliva to the day?
- You need a new family.
- No. He used to pin me down
and he'd do that spit thing
and he suck it back up.
Did that happen to anybody?
Thank you.
Everyone's family's messed up.
Not just mine, Marlon.
- No. But listen, here's
the beauty, right?
- Yeah?
- Is I used to tell my brothers
one day you will be old.
And when you on that deathbed,
I'm farting in your mouth.
- I am Dutch ovening
you. Like that's amazing.
We're back with Marlon Wayans.
That was a look at his new Netflix movie,
"The Curse of Bridge Hollow".
I love this movie.
- Thank you.
- I love, yes.
I watched it with my kids.
- Good.
- You've done a few scary movies.
Do you like scary movies?
You like being a part
Like why this one?
- I, well this one is different.
Most of my scary movies.
I'm glad when you said "I
watched it with my kids."
This is one of the first
movies I've ever done
probably in my career
of doing horror comedy.
And you could actually
watch it with your kids.
- I know. they loved it
- But that's a good thing. Scary movie?
You can't watch that with your kids.
- I'm sure some people.
- Yeah. It's fluids everywhere.
You'll be answering
all kinds of questions.
Same thing with Haunted House.
Haunted House
I was with a doll and doing
all kind of crazy stuff
and you can't watch that with your kids.
But this one is actually appropriate
and it's a good family
movie and I really like it.
Great special effects.
- I love that.
So wait, that, you've said
that your family though
didn't do Halloween when you were younger?
- No. My dad was Jehovah's Witness, so.
- Oh, so you didn't get to do it at all.
- No, me and my brother, we still did it.
We just didn't have no costumes.
Like my dad wouldn't participate.
So I would dress up like Shawn
and Shawn would dress up as me
and they'd be like "Who are you?"
"I'm Shawn and he's Marlon."
We was just begging, basically it wasn't--
- Oh my God
- We just wanted some
money and some free candy.
- When is the first time that
you really did Halloween?
Like dressed up?
- I think I probably
when I was like thirties, when I had kids
that was when I did my first--
- Wait, what? What about your twenties?
- Nah, my dad was still in
my ear, you know what I mean?
- Oh.
- So I still felt like he could spank me.
You seen how skinny I was.
(Kelly laughs)
- But I mean it could
just be a costume party.
- But once my dad hit 60 I was like
I'm celebrating Halloween.
Sit your fat behind down.
'Cause my dad was outta shape then.
And so I was like, I could take you
and it was funny 'cause I wanted
to look good in Halloween.
I didn't want to be in no costume.
So I was Run DMC every
year for like 10 years.
'Cause you just throw on
a dope Adidas tracksuit
and you got your glasses, your Gazelles
and you hit that pose and you fly.
You know what I mean?
- I know. I go the
opposite. I go like weird.
Like, I wanna be like Beetlejuice.
Like I, I go the opposite.
- That's a good one.
- I know!
It's just, I like,
- Do you shrink your
head? How do you do that?
You know what I like about it is the --
I can't say it. Anonymity. There you go.
- Yes.
- Because I go out with
my kids trick or treating
and nobody knows who I
am. So that's kind of fun.
- That's dope.
Because everybody, I've
been famous so long
I can't put on a costume.
They're like "Look at Marlon
Wayans as Beetlejuice."
- Okay, well you turned 50 this summer.
- Yes.
- That's amazing.
Was it a fun party?
- Yes.
(audience cheers)
- That's a big, that's a big birthday.
- I, yeah, I turned 50
and you know, it's funny
'cause I didn't throw one party.
I threw like three.
- Oh!
- Because my family was
gonna throw me a party.
But I looked at the guest
list and it was weird
'cause I know so many
people from the industry
to like, you know friends
to like, you know, family
and you just can't throw
everybody in a party.
You know what I mean?
I look at the guest list,
it was like Nas, Aunt Trudy
And Baby Ivory.
I'm like, Nas don't wanna hang out
with Aunt Trudy and Baby Ivory.
So I separated the parties
and I realized something
I was born on the same day as my mother
and I lost my mom three,
three year, two years ago.
And I gotta tell you, no
birthday's ever gonna be the same.
I could throw 30 parties.
And the best time I had was when I woke up
and I went to her gravesite.
And I just sat there with her and
played her her favorite
music, bought her a cake.
And that was my highlight of my birthday.
But I miss my girl.
- Oh wow.
- Don't start crying now.
- I can't.
- This ain't what this show's about Kelly?
- Oh. I'm like, that's like so beautiful.
- Yeah.
Birthdays will never be
the same without her.
- Oh my gosh! Okay. There's
no segueing from that.
C'mon. Damn.
There's no so segue! There's no so segue!
- C'mon, girl. C'mon.
- You're so sweet.
- C'mon. It's okay.
- I hope my son does that. (laughs)